hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The
Crooked Man okay and some horrific
relief of logic I took a nap in the
infirmary to make myself go faster but
now I need to contemplate why that was
even a good idea in the first place
because obviously there's still a
crooked man walking through these halls
and going to kill me at any moment but I
decided that it was nap time and I'm
gonna be perfectly ok ok ok so people in
comment section were like very little
bit
don't you know markiplier I mean
obviously you with both take a nap but I
mean whatever I don't I don't even know
I don't even want to describe it
cuz I'm standing in DS I don't know
gaseous emissions here because he ate
some really bad three bean salad but who
can't get out oh well Bidoof is a
Pokemon
I haven't played Pokemon since pokemon
red but I know that because everyone
makes fun of Bidoof I think he's
adorable
ok you were one of you guys said that I
could use the hammer which was my
original assumption that I could get
through here a little bit easier if I
use that so we bash our way through that
door and then we go through here and not
out into the hallway but instead through
here but we can't open these so I'm
assuming that that's why I had the
crowbar uh do get in there go along
there's like um Hungarian throat singing
going on in the background is actually
quite straight
oh you man I climb fast when oh wait
aren't i carrying d I'm carrying D right
holy crap this guy is incredibly strong
I have to admit this guy is just a total
badass I can't even begin to describe
how much awesome he is channeling right
now no boy D are you sure you're okay
you don't want to go to the hospital
what if you got poisoned ha I'm fine
head hurts like hell but I feel gross
but I'll get better thanks dude I'd be
screwed without you I owe you my life
there's a water storage in the basement
and I once heard about a leaking gas
only just remember that now it was after
I graduated so I don't know for sure but
I think there was a dispute over the
properties so the school moved in this
God abandoned I see but you really
shouldn't have come if you knew it was
dangerous Shia I just sort of forgot
okay man to think this all happened when
I just came here to relax should've just
stayed home studying it's good to get a
breather sure just not in abandoned
ruins okay that's really something
though you're still studying three whole
years after you graduated well I always
wanted to be a lawyer ever since I was
kid no matter what I will be a lawyer so
I kept studying and I still do there's
no changing my mind
I see but you're awesome yourself
climbing the elevator walk carrying me
your buffer then you look finally
someone recognizes I did go to flight
school sirrah what does that have to do
with being buff that's awesome really
can't judge a book by it's cover yo but
anyway won't you get out of here already
it's all kinds of dangerous here and I'm
not looking after you anymore
I know I know well it was nostalgic and
refreshing while it lasted I'll just
rest here a little and go you do that
I'll be going
oh I guess I'm going now okay bye
goodbye why hold on a second you dropped
something here you wait what huh this
looks like Professor OH
oh well he's gonna realize a horrible
truth of what happened
hey wait go read that now go ahead and
read it you douche huh dreamer the grade
he'll always get hey what's this about
why did the professor
this is how he really felt the music got
really sinister but you supported me you
said I'd be a lawyer someday that was
what you told me
Eydie calm down Oh Dee oh that guy he's
in no condition but that monster is
bound to find him I have to go after him
well in my assumption he would go either
where would he go he'd probably go up to
the room where I found that paper which
was at the top of the stairs in those
the last place I went before I came
downstairs Dee Deirdre darling oh you're
not here um ah crap
where could he have gone he didn't go
back down to the basement did he base
was full of gas I'm sure the Mocs who's
down there
I don't think I should go then he could
have gone back to a classroom this one I
in luck here
No damn it oh no he was in it was it
wasn't that removes this room over here
hello go up here Dee heels painted over
won't open ah I got you Dee Dee there
you are saint goodness
I always knew at least that I wasn't a
genius or anything but why didn't they
just say it cuz respected professor
Andrew cuz he always supported me drop
kind of dumb been teased constantly for
it failed five times double failure but
aren't I free to dream I've always tried
to be a lawyer that's why I still study
so hard what did it have to be like this
was everything I did for nothing I don't
know what to do anymore
dee that's that's life isn't it suck it
up your [ __ ] you shouldn't give up Dee
are you gonna give up on your dreams
just because others make fun of them you
can't give up you want to be a lawyer
then don't give up over some teasing
you're still young and full of life
me I know I chase my dreams recklessly
when I was a student I'll support you
toward your dream so good luck and don't
give up
good luck you're wishing me good luck
that's right
really d what the hell you do know we
just met a lot of it was not good I sure
as hell know that I gotta try harder
really is this really the leap of logic
he's gonna take you got that don't talk
smack cuz she's got a couple years ah be
good luck I don't need it that's the
stupidest thing I've ever seen
calm down I'm commas now nuts to you for
butting in like you know anything forget
about me already like you know jack
about how I feel
leave me the hell alone dee would I did
he just stab me
he just stabbed me didn't he why why
that doesn't make any sense
none you'd never understand how I feel
he stabbed me why did he stab me you
just made a fun of me you like everyone
else pretending to be my friend
what kind of leap of logic does that
happen god game logic
nobody should care about a
oh I have the crooked man kills you did
Oh what the hell
oh okay all right god not die important
Oh cooking man's gonna kill you kill you
so dead he's gonna kill you so dead
always gonna kill you dead Oh get him
get him rip his head off
how's that his head getting ripped off
oh please tell me that was his acting oh
now his head get ripped off hey buddy
how are you doing you do good you look
good
what
okay that was kind of messed up but what
the hell
how much wanna know never never never
gonna give you up never gonna let you
down never gonna run around and hurt you
never gonna make you cry never gonna
kill you till you die then we're gonna
stab you in the bud and desert you oh
man
what kind of leap of logic is it that
that okay I can understand that the
character might not say that and the
character wants to say the suck-it-up
line but that's just silly
that's just silliness pure and simple
why did it have to be like this the loo
that's wife isn't it suck it up your
little [ __ ] you weren't cut out for it
yeah yeah that's how it is you tell them
yeah we're gonna get you up you're
looking at you kind of irritates me you
with your face it's all ugly you need to
wake up but there enough hopeless
idealist in the world as it is do shut
up yeah I'm stupid but keep studying
everyone's lacking in something or
another in your case it was intelligence
Oh sick burn oh you goddamn you wanna
please me bring it bro come at me bro
in my case it was my eyes oh here comes
the heartfelt story about my past ever
since I was a kid I wanted to be a test
pilot I studied hard and made it to
flight school but I was colorblind
strange isn't it you just a few colors
you can't see and suddenly you have no
right to fly it seems obvious to me now
back then I couldn't even comprehend so
I I faked my vision results to get into
school I spent three job I spent three
years playing innocent even managed to
be an honor student but I was found out
well the day of my pilot examiner less
that day I was reduced from an honours
student to a filthy traitor I dropped
out and now I'm just some nobody clerk
I don't mind if you still want to be a
lawyer but I just want to say something
don't trap yourself by narrowing the
road and it rough wasn't it your
childhood dream it certainly was it
still is looking at you I realized it's
not much but I make my own money I have
a girlfriend and I drink with my buddy
but you have a girlfriend I thought you
didn't have a girlfriend and I enjoy my
life for what it is I didn't want to
recognize I'd been sent back but I can't
deny where I am now nor all the work I
put in back then but you did you don't
have a girl are you delusional men are
you happy with what you have now yes so
I didn't quite notice it my life is how
I chose it to be so I shouldn't regret
it
how about you um I won't give up because
it's always been my dream to be a lawyer
I see so there's one more time I'll try
the bar exam but if I fail that's it I
made up my mind I'll give up her good
then but it won't mean those three years
were a waste right David yeah of course
is there any point to staying here let's
go I'll take you home if you want yeah
thanks but before that the Crooked Man
David what's up how did I know hey wha
hey David get out of school I'll keep
them away got it cuz I'm a badass
let's go together this guy's bad news
yeah why don't we do that
he's chase me who knows how many miles
it's me this monster is after I'll take
care of it
wait no that's a bad idea why don't we
do it together that seems like a much
better idea
it just won't die will you I'll finish
you off this time cuz I'm a [ __ ]
badass okay good
I saved come on bring it on I'm assuming
is the same woo you're zippy now it yeah
come on
bring-bring you a [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa aah
what wait a minute I didn't even get a
chance I'm not that badass apparently
what the hell that's hardly fair he
likes it me fast he's like super zippy
fast I just got it oh snap the right way
to stab the right way bro oh god he's
fast okay maybe maybe there's a strategy
to this and I'm not doing it correctly
well I later though as I need to get a
member to one of these guests ha ha
somehow I think I'm hitting him I think
I'm hitting it how many hits is this
gonna take
ah totally cheap but I'll take it I will
take it oh I'm so proud Lee did it
Sonic's plate what are you talking about
FATA gee David you're so damn slow are
you sure you're all right darlin hang on
David all comes up yo oh hi
you could have saved me earlier you okay
David did you finish that thing off yeah
somehow but I don't think it's done for
yet I feel like it'll come back again
what do you what do you mean again
didn't I tell you it followed me all the
way from a distant hotel I don't think
this is over yet I don't get it dude are
you going somewhere now I'd like to but
I don't have a destination the guy I'm
looking for wasn't here so I don't know
where he could be huh
hey hold on I actually found this
earlier any help
Oh Dave's ex machina deus ex where did
you fly in this I found it in the
basement the paper looked pretty new so
thought you just dropped him man place
of regret do you know where this is no
clue but I think it's pretty far from
here take about a day to drive how wait
you don't know where it is but it take
it how do you know I'll never mind I
think I'll check this out so long hold
on are you gonna give me a kiss on the
cheek
you're gonna give you a little kid Eddie
T you said your danger you're looking
for who exactly any dangerous driving
around this late why are you wanna meet
him yeah when is it gonna be if it's
gonna take a day to get there wouldn't
it turned today to be honest I'm not
sure myself though I have sort of an
excuse
uh-huh my point is it doesn't matter why
I want to meet him it's just right now
it feels like I have to I have to go
we'll all right take care of yourself I
will is your house far I'll take you
there don't worry about it I can handle
myself okay be careful then wait oh
you're going to get on tick ah if we
meet again sometime you want to have a
drink or something
of course I look forward to it no oh
come on all the fans were demanding it
right you guys were asking for our scene
- and okay I'm gonna save in the other
spot now not that they need I picked the
bad end
okay who the hell hmm was that my phone
I was sound asleep
a message from Shirley she called me
again what could she want this late
stubborn as Shirley
no maybe she'll call again tomorrow I
gotta go if you say so man you do what
you feel is right a hospital huh must be
abandoned or else it's got terrible
upkeep what's with him in these creepy
places should I go in yes
not just yet because I am all out of
time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
the kitchen
hmm
Oh what what insanity
why is there hair come on the kitchen
sake
oh don't
mara let's go to sleep yeah
going to happen